your competition right now for the
average guy who's watching this who
jacks off five times a week and he plays
video games for like one hour a day but
it's more like four the thing is if you
do a push-up today you have literally
beaten 500 million men how can that not
blow your mind and if you go and do like
a good structured program you'll be in
pretty much every single guy
i think that
the
dating youtube space at the moment is
totally fascinating and it's fragmenting
into loads of little subgroups at the
moment how would you categorize the
content that you make what's the purpose
of the stuff that you put out on youtube
i'd say holistic self-improvements i
love that term more than like
i've taken a bit from everywhere right
i've done the full like hardcore red
pill type of stuff i've ventured into
the black pill so other people don't
have to go and look at their content but
i found this there's never really like a
healthy mix between them
a lot of them will just focus like just
solely on women seeing them as the enemy
trying to be sexist towards them
aggressive towards them a lot of them
just focus on like nihilism and like
this sense of like hopelessness and i
don't think any one pill or space online
really combines anything together to
give like a younger man the
the framework for like a healthy life
going forward revolving around good
relationships and i love the term
holistic self-improvement which is just
okay let's why not why don't we all just
improve as much as we can so of course
we'll try and up our smv we'll try and
like attract more women and everything
but why not do that
alongside things like healthy mental
health practices gratitude mindfulness
learning things about like our childhood
trauma and how that shapes our day in
life
you're right there's no one
pill that's got all of the answers
within it and you can learn bits by
bouncing between them but it seems like
the the most toxic communities are the
ones where someone's got into it and
then never ever left
oh
that was me being the red pill for like
seven years you can like i think you've
taken it as well like you can really
really go steep inside one of these and
when you
stop questioning
the reliability the accuracy of what
like you know the information that you
consume you can so
you can put like such a hindrance on
your growth well that's how cults work
that is precisely how cults work that
you have this leader the leader's word
cannot be questioned all of the
followers
that get co-opted in they all just
believe because you're supposed to
believe and nobody questions anybody's
words and that lack of critical thinking
causes i think about what cults do they
wrap people around it's a geographical
location but also an ideological
location they don't permit them to grow
have you seen my instagram bio
no what's it say i've just changed as a
cult leader
[Laughter]
so maybe that's why you know what i'm on
about
well i did some research on like cults
and religions and i wanted to create
like the first healthy cult where you
actually like voluntarily come in i
voluntarily like tell you yeah you're
joining a cult we're cult of young men
who don't faff anymore like it was
trying to like reduce our drug usage
talk to me about nofap
i think the online space
has got this like
different perception of what it is in my
opinion i think a lot of people think
like it is you know the levitation and
it's going to make you amazing and
everything and you certainly will see a
very very significant change in your
life if you're one of those like
hardcore bankers who like who are going
multiple times a day messed up porn and
everything which to be honest like
there's a fair amount of guys and i have
the authenticity to say yeah 100 i was
not not that messed up but like i was
one of those guys right and so when you
go from this like multiple times a day
to like not maybe let's say once every
three days you're masturbating there's
quite a big difference and that's like i
think as far as a lot of the benefit
does go after that there's like this
again this cult online which is telling
you okay if you ever touch your dick
again like that's that's the perception
that they're pushing on to young young
men if you fap again you've lost the
benefits which that that blows my mind
because that's so unhealthy to tell
young guys it's like telling a beast guy
okay yeah get in get into the gym get
into the gym you should go every day if
you miss a day you lose all of the
progress
that's that's heartless man that's so
like
i've come across more young men who have
been pained by nofap than who have just
like got problems with like masturbation
yeah because they get like this
this um
existential crisis where now they feel
like more of a loser because they keep
failing nofap and it's just like simple
habit science that's how i always ask
them the question like when when did you
start jacking off and they'll say you
know age 30 and then they're 19 right
now
so six years you've been building up
this habit you found nofap a few weeks
ago six years you've been building it up
and you just think you're gonna break
the habit just like that it's like at
least for me it took me about five years
to get onto like nofap where like i just
it's honestly like it's not in my life
at all i don't even think about it i
often forget that porn and masturbation
is the thing but i was so hard on myself
for the first like year or so thinking
like i should get to day 90 or something
because it's not just about like you
know the discipline and willpower it's
about the problem like we've been
building up this habit for like 10 years
and it's like it's gonna take some time
to like reduce it down i wonder how many
people would benefit from nofap that
aren't like
pathological fappers
the people who aren't completely
addicted and see it as a vice because
one of the things that i've realized
recently is that with a lot of the
things we do that we don't like
ourselves for doing let's say it's using
our phone too much or maybe it's junk
eating on a night time or whatever it
might be
i would say that less than 50 of the
problem is the actual activity that you
do
and most of the problem comes from the
story that you tell yourself about the
type of person you are for having done
that action so a lot of the benefits
that i think we get from going through
any type of personal development
actually comes from a reframing around
capturing our own agency to do with that
particular action do you know what i
mean
yeah very very well said that's like
it's like this bell curve where at first
you don't really think that the original
thing is the problem the vice is the
problem so masturbation or let's say the
junk food eventually you start to see
people talk about you know quitting it
and everything like this is when you
hate the thing you hate the thing but
you can't stop it and so there's often
this
negative
mental well-being stage when you're
trying to start a new which everyone
kind of knows which is like when you
finally start thinking okay i've got to
go to the gym i've got to lose weight
i've got to do this it's like you just
feel like [ __ ] for a little while
because you hate the thing but you still
have a habit or even an addiction to the
thing
and
you've actually brought up like a
fantastic point recently i've been
thinking that potentially the best way
to actually improve things like this
whether it's no fap or healthy and it's
actually way more about the self-image
and like the beliefs that we have about
ourselves more than it actually is you
know like the stereotypical advice of
like oh like you know install the
website blocker and like don't buy the
junk food and everything because
if you're just kind of like hide the
stuff away from you like it's like a
child just saying i can't i can't see
the pawn anymore so i can't be addicted
or like you know i didn't buy the junk
food so i can't eat it anymore but it's
it's more
if you me and you have a chocolate bar
in front of us right now we're probably
not gonna eat it because it's just it
doesn't really align with our identity
we're gonna think oh it's just not i
don't want to put it onto my fitness pal
and just have the regret there like oh
yeah four hundred calories for a month
for yourself man
at the moment i can eat whatever the
[ __ ] i want
i had charlie hooper from charisma on
command on the show earlier this week
and uh we were talking about the fact
that there is a tension between
assisting yourself to not do the things
that you don't want to do by hiding them
away from you or by creating constraints
in your life so you don't play league of
legends so you snap the game in half and
delete your xbox account or whatever and
there is a question look i know that
you're not a gamer because you just said
that
any gamers who's listening to you right
now
is it pc only
that they're giving up
yeah
the problem that you have
is that
there is a part of you that feels
defeated by that like oh i'm defeatist
because i've assisted so the same as you
saying like look is keeping the junk
food out of the house actually putting a
blinker over your eyes so that you can't
deal with the underlying problem that's
causing the junk eating in the first
place i would be tempted to say that you
need to give yourself assistance in the
first place like environment design is a
huge part of habit building and it's
probably the case that the tools you get
in the beginning that get you across the
first river
isn't the boat that you're supposed to
carry across land to get you across the
second river it's like look the thing
that you did that got you here isn't the
thing that's going to get you there so
if you decide to assist yourself by
putting a
pawn blocker on your laptop or getting
rid of all the junk food out of your
house or doing whatever it might be
that's fine and then
that will allow you to at least gain
some momentum when your ability to stick
to the habit is its weakest
then we start to build up we start to
build up okay now i've got a bit more
capacity i've got a bit more capacity
and now maybe i can look to reintroduce
looking at where does my compulsion
to eat junk food on an evening come from
oh it's actually because i'm bored
because i don't have anything to do
maybe it's because i'm lonely oh well
now that i've given myself room away
from the junk food i can actually start
to fill that with something else
that's a really really good point
actually yeah so the original uh
environmental design i often critique it
i often say even though every like
scientist disagrees with me and they say
you know like willpower's limited i'm
like i feel like i'm the one guy right
now telling everyone rely on willpower
instead because
like in my story like the environmental
design would never even work because
it's decided okay i can not buy the junk
food inside the store
but then we've we've already got some at
home i can okay i'll throw it all out
you know i just want to go i'm going on
a diet i'm gonna throw out the junk food
but then like my girlfriend's gonna come
back home with like extra food or i go
to to work and it's like it's a customer
service job at the time so like
[ __ ] are bringing in like a lot
of snacks and stuff so me in that so
it's like if the idea is like you're
gonna say no once inside of the shop the
thing is if if all you have is the
environmental design you probably aren't
gonna manage the entire environment
around you whereas it really is that
level of willpower and even like the
self-image the belief that any given
time like we we have junk food in the
house all the time i finally love that
[ __ ] but like i'll walk past the kitchen
no problem every like every single day
for like two years there's the stuff
that i used to binge eat on but the
reason why is because i always try to do
this thing of like no no don't go into
the kitchen like tell my dad not to buy
the crisp eventually i i just it's kind
of like psychopathic but i got my
favorite snacks just set them on the
desk and just looked at them and i don't
think many people have done this but
like
ah
the weird thoughts that you get about
yourself when you do that like seriously
get the best snacks that you've ever
gotten even drugs as well so i did this
with weed and i just put it on top of
the table just with like a notepad side
journaling and it just makes you feel
like a crackhead because you're like oh
like you know like okay it's the the
experiment right so i'm gonna be writing
a [ __ ] ode to my drug i've got it
i've written a poem i'm outside of its
window with a pair of roses
the boombox in there
talk to me so you've mentioned there
about this sort of um chasm of
difficulty you've got self de
development depression is something that
you talk about what's that
that's
one of the first stages it's like
essentially let's say you're a normal
person you just kind of all you know
about self-improvement is like oh yeah
like go to the gym but eventually you
find the space online you start finding
the books of self-help and everything
some people seem to get stuck in level
one and i think that a fair amount of
like healthy people seem to breeze past
this stage so the healthy people that
i've for example i've spoke to have
coached they'll find out about
meditation no fat whatever and they'll
implement it fairly straightforward
exercise i'll tell them okay yeah start
exercising a few almost every single day
they'll do it no problem there's so many
people who because it's only because of
mental health that they're stuck in
stage one which is that they know what
they should be doing they just can't
seem to do it so for these people for
example they would have had an idea
let's say nice and simple to exercise
and they'll be like oh yeah like you
know today's the day i'm going to
exercise right you know it feels really
relevant they'll look back and be like
wait it's been three weeks since i
watched that motivational video and i
said i was gonna exercise again they
just they fall straight into the same
patterns we could grab this person take
them inside the gym with us make them do
the best work out of their lives and
they're so hyped and everything like you
know they're making some gains they're
not gonna come again for like the next
month and it's this self-improvement
depression because
they are now in the space of hearing
about people like me and even you
yourself who have made progress and
we're talking about you know the
fantastic like stuff that comes from
this and everything and
they don't get to enjoy that they just
can't seem to get consistent in any of
the habits they can't seem to make
meditation work for them they you know
it doesn't work and everything they've
tried so many times and it's a very very
depressing and like scary place to be
because you feel quite vulnerable and
like
you're no longer satisfied and oblivious
to your old life of you know video games
and porn and everything but now you know
the dangers of them you've watched the
videos you know oh like i used to play
video games but now i don't play video
games and look at me everyone i've got
i've got girls now and like some little
guys watching that thinking like wait
but i want girls but like i can't he
can't he kind of snap his league of
legends disc in half as you would see
are you familiar with plato's allegory
of the cave do you know that story
no okay so plato gives this story about
um three men that are chained up inside
of a cave and they're looking at a wall
in the shadows yeah the shadows on the
wall right and then one of them gets
freed he goes out into the world he
suffers pain
he can't see because it's so bright he's
been in the darkness and then eventually
after looking at the reflection of the
world in the water and then finally the
world in its full color he starts to see
that oh wow the previous world that i
thought this was all that existed is
only a mere shadow of what is available
for us and he comes back into the cave
and then he looks at his friends he's
stumbling around he can't see because
he's now in darkness he's back he's
regressed back to the previous version
of himself to try and communicate
between where he is and where the people
that he wants to bring up with him is
and he says to them look guys like this
isn't the real world i promise you out
there there is something better it's
more blissful it's fuller and
they're not happy they said look you
can't even see in here anymore you can't
see inside of the cave this was supposed
to be the place that you knew and he
can't see because he's seen what is true
he comes back he's ostracized by the
people that live at a lower resolution
than him and the argument from plato is
look this is the job of a philosopher
it's to try and peer through it's to see
what the truth is and it's to then try
and tell people who need to be leveled
up from that but there is a pain
associated with that if the if true hell
is when the person that you are meets
the person that you could have been
every time that you get to see the
person that you could be continue to
write rise up and you see that through
youtube videos with people that are
doing things and crushing it and killing
it and instagram and models and tabla
every time that you see that
the ceiling of potential continues to
move away and you need to try and catch
up with it now so you just continue to
feel this chasm between where you are
and where you could be
wow and that's got to be painful
it kind of reminds me of the analogy of
the crabs in a bucket mentality
so that's very common in
self-improvement whether one of the guys
in the friendship group will find
self-improvement start working on
themselves and find that no one else
seems to want to like climb up in the
same way and it's it's it just blows
your mind because you want to go to your
friend and say like boys like i've been
lifting some weights and i finally feel
confident you know we're all nerds and
stuff but like look at me i've got some
biceps and stuff and they'll make fun of
you they're like not like we don't do
that type of stuff you're [ __ ] gay
yeah oh like you're going to do that's
gay like
come on man that's the worst thing dude
this is my least favorite thing about
british british culture
my least favorite thing by far like
that tall poppy syndrome
is holding so many young people back
that could be amazing that have got
desires for growth that want to go and
do something different but are terrified
because every time they try to do
something different their immediate
social circle takes the piss out of them
what's that tall puppy syndrome yeah so
you can imagine that you look in a field
and there's a field of poppies and
there's a tall one as you go through
which one are you going to chop down
the most likely one that you're going to
chop down is the tall puppy it's called
tall poppy syndrome i don't know the
full history of it i think it's an
australian term originally but yeah tall
poppy syndrome something sticks out
something grows faster than everything
else that's the one that gets chopped
so which one would you rather be like
amongst the masses and just kind of
seeing the same thing as everyone else
or the one up here who kind of like
lives fast dies young dude that's a good
question that's a genuinely good
question so when at the first ever time
that i saw jordan peterson live someone
said to him the depth of my
consciousness causes me to suffer is it
a blessing or a curse to feel everything
so deeply i'm like this is a really
[ __ ] smart question because a lot of
the people that are in the audience
they've maybe started to step out of
plato's cave they've started to look
around and go look
[ __ ] maybe maybe there is more to life
but by taking that
decision you are inevitably going to
suffer as well
and jordan said basically
you
the only solution would be to regress
back to a lower state of consciousness
right to go into some lower resolution
version of the world and a lot of people
escape from their insights with drugs
with alcohol with sex with extreme
sports sometimes people even take their
own lives in an effort to try and get
away from this because they don't feel
like they can find a solution and he
said look it's too bloody late to
regress back
what you need to do is take more of the
thing that poisons you until you turn it
into a tonic that girdles the world
around you he's like you
have not less consciousness but more you
go deeper you go further in and i'm
watching this thing in my head even now
man reciting it the hairs stand up on
the back of my neck i'm like that is so
correct you need to go deeper you need
to take more of the thing that you think
is the challenge
and you turn it into a tonic that
girdles the world around you
um
that's making me think of like the
beginner who starts in the gym and the
first workout just absolutely kills them
they're like oh my gosh you know how do
people do this it's like my muscles are
so sore
and if they stop right now
or even in any sport like kickboxing
rides with if they stop right now every
single time they try to get back into
the gym they'll feel the same pain or
even worse than normal and it's so
interesting that the more you go the
less pain that you'll actually feel
until eventually the pain actually
becomes the pleasure like it's like we
actually like like if my chest doesn't
get sore i'm like oh like i guess i'm a
little bit like i didn't even didn't
even hit that [ __ ]
now i'm like oh like oh my god yes boys
like i'm i'm finally feeling chest dumbs
whereas before when you get them
our perception of pain
especially in in
positive habits is so so skewed when you
are like when you're currently in
plato's uh cave
because i'm guessing the first character
as he walked outside his eyes is burning
and everything eventually he starts the
scene yeah the first thing that he sees
he looks at the world
through the reflection of a lake so he
walks and walks and walks until he hits
a lake and then he doesn't see the world
first
the first thing he actually sees is a
reflection of the world right which is
kind of like the way that shadows work
so he sees a lower resolution of a
higher resolution thing and then
eventually as his eyes finally begin to
adjust he's able to look around and see
the sky in the trees and the birds and
the grass
um so here's a [ __ ] cool story
there's a place in
austin called kuya which is a uh
ketamine psychotherapy
nad iv vitamin ib recovery center that
has sauna and cold bath and you do
what's called contrast therapy so you go
to a sauna that goes up to 230 degrees
and then you get into a cold tub single
cold tub up to your neck hands wrists
full works and it's just above freezing
it's like three three to six degrees
celsius um and when you're in the cold
tub
it's a very unique kind of pain
because there's nothing to distract
yourself you know when you're doing a
workout the pain is relative to the
effort that you're putting in this is
completely passive pain it's simply
because you're sitting there and it's
short you're only in there for three
minutes three or four minutes right
but if you can sit
and just
think about the sensation that you're
feeling when you sit in the cold water
it stops being pain it stops even being
cold it's no longer cold
it's this bizarre
electric
sort of like it feels like lemon it
feels like all of these things that kind
of
wrap around the sensation that have [ __ ]
all to do with cold electricity and
citrus and [ __ ]
and dude it's the best mindfulness
exercise just sitting in there and
feeling your own compulsion to want to
get out to breathe to feel pain to feel
pleasure it's wild
i was going to say as you were telling
me that story that just sounds like pure
mindfulness training that like as in
cold showers if you try and fight the
pain fight the cold off it's so much
worse but it's so weird that if you
submit yourself to the cold if you allow
it
suddenly like it's not as good it's the
same with exercise and everything that
we do the pain
only is
suffering
if you fight it
but if you allow it like that the pain
actually just becomes that pleasure
that's what surrender is that's fully
what surrender is so the first time that
i went i went with my buddy zac big
youtuber uh and we got in and we were
both fine then he got his got in his own
head about being in the cold and a
couple of times he got out early and
then the next time that we went we got
in the cold thing and he's
i'm thinking you're not going to last 25
seconds and he got out because he was in
his own head and then eventually after a
couple of more sessions
he breaks that and then he's back in
nothing's changed his physiology hasn't
changed at all but his relationship to
surrendering to the thing that he's
supposed to do and this is coming back
to what we said before right about
framing what your habits mean to you
you're getting in the cold tub look is
this an opportunity for you to do
something which is going to make you
feel amazing which is a fascinating
experience and a deep dive into your own
motivations inside of your brain for
three minutes that feels like 30
or is it you battling the cold is it you
versus this thing and i better breathe
because if i don't breathe and i'm all
tense
nah man
there's a cue that i got from one of the
guys i was training with and he said
what would this be like if it was easier
and it's such a dope cue like what would
this thing that i'm doing be like
if it was easier and it was we were in a
plank and that was when he said it to me
it's like hey man like just remember
like what would this be like if it was
easier and you find yourself actually
easing into the movement and feeling
stronger because you're not tense
everywhere your tense where you need to
be
so such a [ __ ] good insight
i really like that i read it in um greg
mcewen's second book effortless
yep yeah i really love that concept
that that comes up in so much like every
habit i can think of right now i found
that if you think it's going to be
difficult like there's the story you
tell yourself
it's going to be difficult making
youtube videos every day absolutely it's
easy now and
because of that it is easy
because i think it's easy and it's fun
it's going to be easy and fun whereas if
for example before this call
i thought yeah it's going to be a fun
conversation with chris and that's
exactly what it feels like but if i
could have been tense like oh my god
this guy he's got 200 followers he got
like 200k followers he's got a nice
jawline and everything i'm gonna get
anxious
then it would have felt very like
tense and it would just whatever frame
of mind you put yourself in it seems
like the world just reacts in that way
for you yeah dude i want to talk about
britney spears we need we
simply have to talk about this
so for the people that haven't seen uh
one day ago britney spears posted a two
photo carousel on her instagram with the
caption free woman energy has never felt
better
and she is completely naked apart from a
long pair of white socks and she has an
emoji of a heart over her vagina
and
a flower over her nipple
and then there's another photo if you
swipe right there is another photo where
she's
kind of like
wide-legged
and the with the same the same emoji
setup so you can go and see this and
it's got nearly 3 million likes but
perhaps unsurprisingly she turned
comments off
um
what's your
what's your thoughts on that i'm sorry
so there's a youtuber called alexander
grace i sent you the link to his youtube
video he was saying polygamy he's gonna
be the new i'm watching that one and um
he said it in like a fantastic way where
he said imagine if the real feminists of
the 1900s saw what was happening today
like they would they would think that
you were lying if we told them oh yeah
by the way like women are fighting to be
more sexualized than ever to like to for
free post pictures of themselves so that
millions of tens of millions of people
can see it
the real feminists of the 1900s would
think that you were joking they would
think that you were just like mocking
them
that this is like it's the sad state
where now
i especially think of like the young
women and the teenagers who who are kind
of seeing like their idols post this and
obviously we model after the people that
we look up to and it's kind of like okay
so
in this bizarre counter-intuitive way
the modern sort of feminist narrative
has
encourages women more than ever
to show off their bodies to be
promiscuous which is kind of like the
counter-intuitive aim of the 1900s
movements certainly not a linear
progression between the two dude the
thing that i [ __ ] think
we need to all apologize to a dad
and say look dad maybe you were right
you see that court case do you see where
he was basically oh right okay so
the story seems like britney spears's
dad had control over her entire life
she her estate which included her back
cat log of records um i think it was
like even to do with her finances how
she could spend money it was it was
pretty severe right and it seemed a bit
sinister as well especially the way it
was portrayed in the press i don't know
the ins and outs of the court case but
it didn't seem
fantastic but also
britney's had some um
challenges mentally in the past which i
think was what had legitimated that in
the first place so anyway there was this
big back and forth and it was hashtag
free britney was going on for ages right
they wanted to give her her life back
and i don't know what the current
situation of that is i feel like she
might have got more of a liberty back
from her father but you think britney if
this is the first thing that you do
after getting if you post a fully naked
selfie twice on instagram
to prove your own sanity and the fact
that you don't need your father i'm like
i i don't know if we were right i don't
know if we were right
save britney maybe save britney not free
britney
i think to be honest
you and i are looking at this from quite
a level-headed perspective
which isn't really the general consensus
of the modern world around us whereas
okay so we're looking at this in like a
quite critical way but i think the
overwhelming majority of people will see
this as a positive act for like feminism
and for the act of um
expressing their sexuality they'll see
like this is a confident thing like a
brave thing to do
i'm so
maybe i have too much faith in humanity
but but people can let us know in the
comments right if you think that
what your opinion of this is whether
britney is
liberating herself and
experimenting with the sovereignty of
her own body and her own social media
platform
or if this is
somebody that could do with a bit of
help and needs a phone call from a
friend like it doesn't
seem to me i i would be
interested to speak to the person that
says like go britney after that
um and it just seems like a bad pr move
as well you've just come out of a court
case where your dad had control of
everything because he was worried that
you're going to lose your head and then
you
i don't know
for some people there's no such thing as
bad people
oh yeah well i mean britney's
come on britney it's been a while how
long was like her first single 20
probably 25 years ago or some [ __ ] but
that's another interesting thing we were
talking about this offline
um what happens when you very quickly
gain status and think about child stars
um and this is here's an interesting one
for you man
britney spears macaulay culkin
and
brett weinstein eric weinstein jordan
peterson
people at kind of the opposite ends of
life and maturity but both of which can
be just gifted global renown immediately
how the [ __ ] you supposed to deal with
that status like the human brain was not
meant to be able to receive
international acclaim and be known by
millions and millions of people
like like that
honestly that's why you see so many of
these like child celebrities with mental
breakdowns like it used to be
in quite horrifying ways to be quite
kind of funny to the general population
i think either it was britney spears or
madonna or something like trimmed their
head off the hair off and everyone was
laughing about it and everything but
it's only now as more like as we were
saying like normal people are starting
to get fame and you know
you and i are branching into like the
dark territory where we're like somewhat
normal somewhat not and like we can
start to see like we haven't spoke about
this but we
you must get some kind of like hate
comments every now and then it does like
mess you up sometimes because
we haven't even fathomed the power of
the internet yet and when you do read a
comment it's in my belief that it feels
exactly like a person in front of you
saying that and when we do get like a
critical comment from someone it's this
evolutionary thing inside of us that
like kicks up you know puts us into
fight or flight thinking okay if you
don't act right you'll be kicked out of
the tribe imagine that
with 10 people that's scary imagine that
with 100 well that's life-threatening
now imagine it was like literally a
million people
no wonder these like these guys are like
literally taking naked pictures of
themselves like hopefully they'll get
getting lots
i would love to know the
the motivation behind that that's uh
photo
so [ __ ] interesting but you are right
like
people
remember the insults and forget the
blessings that negativity bias is a hell
of a drug and it's everywhere
but
i don't know les would not be swayed by
that les would be completely fine and he
would just
get stuck into what he's got to do next
all right so give me give me your
thoughts on red pill youtube
yeah um it's mixed because a fair amount
of people in somewhat including myself
have found some value in them and it's
there is absolutely value in having like
all the men give you wisdom and you know
they'll record videos and they'll say
for example like don't pedestalize women
they're just normal people and
everything the issue is that
those type of videos don't really do
well on youtube what does better is like
okay we hate women now and treat them
like garbage and here's how to like [ __ ]
them and like you know throw them out
and everything it's like how to do like
degenerate type of stuff
and the issue now is
the internet's very very nuanced and so
any kind of like red pill youtuber that
you're going to come across is usually
on this side of quite like quite a
degenerate negative hateful hostile
personality
and i i've certainly like i'm not even
exempt from this i've certainly branched
into this multiple times
um the issue is
that what does best for views and for
likes and for growth on youtube which is
an abnormal you know so it's a business
at the end of the day it's how people
make a living
that isn't what what is best for a young
man's mind so the red pill youtubers who
are very popular right now
are
almost entirely just
a negative influence in my opinion they
do teach some things so for example a
young man who's who stumbled onto the
red pill youtubers will for example
learn something which will help him with
the next girl he speaks to but the issue
with that is that by emulating the red
pill youtubers that he sees the only
girls that he can attract are similar to
the girls that that red bull youtuber
are attracting and the red pill youtuber
if he says all women are hoes
and then he's teaching yo yeah like
here's how to text girls well
he said he's telling you how to text
hoes so now the young man who's
following that advice any good healthy
woman
is not going to be attracted to the way
he'd like text for in this example only
the hoes are going to be attracted to it
so it becomes this self-fulfilling
prophecy and like people said this to me
multiple times as i was going through my
red pill journey myself but i couldn't
really understand it you know they're
the blue pillars we can't trust them and
everything up until you really do like
take a huge step back and you realize
like you've just pigeonholed yourself
to attract the women that you actually
do hate
dude
i mean think about here's a good example
think about the girls that fresh and fit
invite round
like
they purposefully go out of their way to
find the thoughtiest most ratchet
degenerate girls that they can from the
streets of miami and they invite them
around and they have some drinks and
then they use it as their opportunity to
outwit the only other people in miami
that they can
who are these
club nightclub girls and then use that
to
like their intellect stands on the
shoulders of girls that are five
tequilas deep
and
oh my god dude i'm [ __ ] adamant i'm
[ __ ] adamant that the fact that fresh
from fresh and fit
is seen as an alpha male by some corners
of the internet i'm [ __ ] certain that
that is one of the four horsemen of the
apocalypse
like that is the biggest forget covid
forget trump forget january 6th the fact
that that man is seen as an alpha is the
worst comment on culture in the modern
era that i could give
which one is fresh he's the one that
always sounds like he's got food in his
mouth
[Laughter]
he just got rumbled for being on a
seeking arrangement so he has this chick
on the
channel and he invites around and they
start talking about how i know that
she's different she's this sort of a
girl she meets him at this boat party
then everybody finds that she's got this
tick tock account where she says the
only type of guys that she likes and
then just switches to a photo of a
bucket load of cash
she's got a channel on seeking
arrangements and it's like luxury
lifestyle fitness lifestyle exclusive
parties
and it turns out that that's how he met
her he's got this weird story about how
he was at a party in miami with this
basketballer and then this basketballer
said oh i [ __ ] that girl as well on
your instagram hey why don't you come
back to my where's the good parties
tonight and then fresh ends up taking
him around and ends up having like
sex with
five girls in one night or something
like dude this is like jay from the
in-betweeners
this legitimately sounds like so i had
one over there and i was [ __ ] with my
toe and you think oh my god what the
[ __ ] is wrong with these people
yeah i'm not gonna lie man
my first perception of them once like i
saw like quite a lot of like click-baity
content and you know there's just girls
asking the thumbnail and everything and
it is definitely entertaining to watch
because it is just like kind of
degenerate [ __ ] that you know you like i
don't want the door to open but i don't
want my mom to walk in i'd rather just
switch pawn on it
[Laughter]
but um
this just the issue is right with stuff
like that again it's it's inherently
just negative media there's some people
replying you know they said i don't know
but it's really really helped people
it's like i don't think it would have i
think any realizations or insights that
you really got from at least the the
show that they do with the girls it's
just kind of like you need to watch one
episode or just read wrong
books it's just it's like oh like oh
like women are like 70 it's like they
just reply in the exact same thing
they've just got different girls and
it's just like young men are consuming
it just as an addiction to like their
youtube like you know content
consumption i will go to say though that
they're
they do shows with like other guys so
they've done shows with like roller
tomassie jay waller and um
sterling cooper and those ones it's so
different like i wish they did more
because they're actually given some like
great wisdom and it was a totally
different vibe where they're thinking of
like the young man and they think okay
guys you should like focus on your
credit score and everything it's like
that's some like good ass advice right
there but
the issue is like that doesn't sell
those ones will get a lot less views
just
on the thumbnail that's what we want to
see we kick these hoes out like that's
what everybody wants it's a it's a drama
channel someone said what was it
it's jerry springer for the tick tock
generation
that's what that's what someone [ __ ]
commented about it here's the thing and
i i'd be interested to know if you're
the same when i first started watching
fresh and fit
kevin samuels
there's a part of me that i noticed that
gets satisfied
by watching that like yeah yeah you
[ __ ] you take those thoughts down you
take those [ __ ] down i'm like
where are you coming from like what part
of me is it that takes satisfaction from
watching
guys that are prepped
[ __ ] on
girls
that have just come to come and sit in a
podcast studio it's the better part like
the part of you that still remembers
getting rejected from girls and
everything it's like this is like us
indulging in that thing over here
yeah that's it because to imagine
to how many guys that is so attractive
to because how many guys okay this
that's a part of us right now if we're
doing okay with the girls it's like a
part of us still remembers and like you
know is hateful for the fact that we got
rejected by this one girl or by hundreds
of girls imagine how many guys are like
literally not attracting any women
whatsoever all they have it's not even a
part that is just them it's just hateful
resentful and then they go into a show
where girls get made fun of and you know
the girl says something but he's like no
but here's the fact like you didn't you
didn't research like we did like that
that guy's gonna feel like some kind of
fulfillment from that like yes like
finally like they're getting put in
their place it is so attractive to the
the huge proportion of guys who have
been hurt by women yeah yeah it is and
it feels like vindication and it feels
like catharsis as well you have these
these guys there that uh
and i think that's one of the reasons
why you get a particular type of very
loyal following for them
which is
they almost feel like they're the best
of us
you know they're the tip of the spear
that's delivering the words to the girls
that righteously should have been [ __ ]
on long ago you know if i went back and
told that girl that snubbed me in the
nightclub four years ago that i still
remember because i haven't done any self
work or meditation or being to see a
[ __ ] therapist which i definitely
need
that's them saying
to all of the girls that have ever
rejected you what you always wanted to
say
um
so it feels nice
like i can
emphasize with the hundreds of thousands
of young men who are actually watching
this with a sense of enjoyment me too
because they didn't get to ever say this
stuff but the thing is like
be bitter would be better and this is
what they're choosing right now there's
no growth coming from this but it is
that sense of instant gratification of
pleasure of just thinking like oh yeah
like
at least a part of you feels like that
you're like fulfilled when you get a
sense of like revenge against the person
who hurt you yeah well one of the things
as well i think you talked about this is
that
a lot of the the content that i don't
like that comes out of the manosphere
red pill youtube space
is the stuff that is predicated on
[ __ ] on women rather than raising up
men
that that
that puts me in the least
positive sum mindset
it puts me in the least grateful place
it makes me feel anxious it makes me
feel on edge it makes me feel it's like
the difference between it's like that's
my dopamine system as opposed to my
serotonin system i don't feel good i
don't feel
nice i don't feel connected i feel
agitated and anxious and i get pleasure
but i get pleasure with this sort of
it's like it's like watching some like
[ __ ] up porn and then afterwards
feeling a little bit disgusted at
yourself for what you've just watched
and yeah it's not that when i watch that
stuff it's not my highest like my
highest self isn't coming through that's
not adonis or les that's
that's geoffrey
that's jeffrey it really is man and it's
it's the problem with the internet the
new ones like
i could use this explanation for
everything we talk about the internet is
turning into like such a negative place
because that's what sells that's what
we're clicking on seeing a girl get
kicked out of the studio is a lot more
attractive than like seeing the same
guys talk about like oh here's his five
three one how to increase your credit
score yeah yeah because like you know
this is this is more valuable but the
thing is
are we even looking for value anymore
are we just looking for like cheap
entertainments and so this is the one
that sells and the issue with this is
like there is a certain value with this
but it's a negative influence on your
personality and at least for me when
when i was fully consumed by this type
of content even before fresh and fit
came out
it's my personality was [ __ ] trash
like i know like a lot of guys
i was like i saw girls as like the enemy
to conquer and so it's the pickup artist
stage a lot of guys go through and it
never saw them as like a person to like
this
this sounds blue pill to see how deep
i've went into it where like i've got to
even catch my blue pill now like is he
is he trying to convert me to blue
politician or something
i used to see girls as like
not
someone to like sort of build things
like as on the same team
they were almost the enemy even if we
were doing good together i was always
like wary of them
i think
yeah like i always thought like i had to
conquer them in like a very
negative way whereas recently like i've
taken a big step back from that therapy
as you said meditation journaling
reading books on dating reading books on
attachment styles and i think the
childhood stuff is like very very
important here and i realize now it's
like i love being around women like i've
made video clickbait videos and again
it's like negative like um your thing
sells i made videos saying like i hate
women and stuff but it's to get the
click and then i say you know different
things on it but it's like i've actually
started to love being around women and
love having that feminine energy around
me and it's like the moment that you
kind of like level things up with the
feels it's such like a beautiful
experience that i was always ignorant to
because i was entirely focused on like
the number clothes and the lay clothes
and when you're doing it as like a
mathematician and you're thinking okay
okay i've got like a three percent
success rate so i've just got to go up
to 100 girls it's like you're literally
seeing them more as like a number than
you are a human being who could be a
compliment to your life well dude the
red pill pickup at least pickup was
started by aspergic and autistic guys
that had no idea how to communicate to
women so the fact that there's a lot of
sexual market value peaks graphs [ __ ]
pictograms and scores out of 10. it
doesn't surprise me because that's what
a lot of the people that began this
movement thinking you know there were
programmers coders nerds that couldn't
get women and there's this zero-sum
mentality in the manosphere i was
listening to the mating grounds podcast
have you heard of this
okay so tucker max who is the used to be
the ceo of scribe media created the frat
eye genre wrote i hope they serve beer
in hell like basically
[ __ ] girls and threw up in bathrooms
for a decade and then wrote about it and
created new york times bestsellers did a
ton of psychotherapy and uh psychedelics
and now was flipped the other way with
jeffrey miller who wrote the mating mind
he's one of the like premier
evolutionary psychologists that focuses
on mating dynamics um and they did a
podcast and it stopped
eight years ago
so
it is one of the best podcasts that you
can go back and listen to it's called
mating grounds it's so [ __ ] dope a
guy that's field tested and a guy that's
got the academic chops to go with it
talking about the fundamentals of male
female attraction dating dynamics but
they say
they're talking about pickup but you see
and this is the fascinating things it's
like eight years old right this episode
that i listened to this morning
and it's the same [ __ ] dynamics it's
not neil strauss and mystery and pickup
and real social dynamics anymore it's
now
fresh and fit and kevin samuels and rolo
tomasi and red pill and manosphere and
alpha and beta and black pill and bloop
like
that's the language the language has
changed but the dynamics are exactly the
same and they're saying the entire pick
apart this community sees
any woman's gain as a man's loss and any
man's gain is a woman's loss so they see
a very adversarial relationship they go
into a club and they talk about pick up
like you pick something up it's an
action that you do they talk about game
and banging and it's all of these terms
that if you break them down it's all to
do with a very aggressive zero-sum
mentality
that they're saying that if you bet a
woman it's almost her loss
that's the mentality that pickup went
into it with and i think that you still
see that now it's this adversarial
relationship as opposed to a positive
sum mentality i'm like [ __ ] man i don't
want to be a part of that at all
that's interesting do you feel like
they might have like a hidden sense of
self-awareness that they see
okay if the woman's losing out when if
she's having sex with him it's almost
because they're aware of the fact that
they aren't like good men
yep i think so and i think as well that
when you
when you obsess so much
over the dynamics it takes you out of
the moment now like you can have
you can critique women that go on all
night stand at one night stands all you
want but you still want a one-night
stand as a young guy
so you're asking women to adhere to
standards that you're not encouraging to
adhere to in your real life
hang on that there's something [ __ ]
going on there you can't point a finger
at women and say you're a [ __ ] if you
have a one night stand then go out and
use all of the tricks that you found
from neuro-linguistic programming to
pick up to neg into all of that [ __ ] to
then get them into bed and then feel
disgusted at the woman for having done
it it's like [ __ ] me there is no
positivity in that situation like every
single step of the way is negative
and you know i think that there probably
are some norms that we need to readdress
around casual sex i think that people
probably do
give away their bodies too quickly and i
think that recreating a sense of
sacredness around
putting yourself inside of someone
else's body is probably a pretty good
thing to do i think that would be
generally good for society
but
you still need to see like how [ __ ]
negative and degenerate most of this
stuff is
100 agreed and that honestly that was me
that was like i was the judgmental guy
okay women should be shouldn't be having
casual sex work it was it was what i
wanted and so now i mock that sort of
personality type using the jeffree
character saying like you know women are
all [ __ ] but why won't they be micellar
it's like they don't actually hate women
for being [ __ ] these aren't like
philosophical men who understand the
detriment of a society that engages in
casual sex these are just guys who are
pissed off that they're not the ones
women are having sex with they're not
they don't like it it's easier for them
to say oh yeah you know because women
shouldn't have sex because it's bad for
them it's bad because it's easier for
them to say that than it is to say like
yeah they shouldn't you know they
hopefully could just have sex with me
but they don't want to so they shouldn't
be having casual sex
but you're you're absolutely right and i
think
that's something literally one of the
biggest things in my mind right now is
like the sacredness of
sex and how to like reduce casual sex
i'll be completely honest like i'm
actually struggling with that if
there's a woman i'm attracted to and she
seems to be back into me
there's been so many times where you
know recently i've been thinking okay no
more casual sex i'm into like either
relationships and love and everything
but
i'm in bed just as fast like that it's
like i can't tell if it's like an
addiction or something but
i find it so hard to restrain myself
from engaging in that well remember that
you're talking you've got two systems
that are running here man like the one
that says i want to put my penis inside
of that girl
is a lot more subconscious and a lot
more ancient than this one that says
remember adonis i need to focus in the
morning i need to make sure that i go
and do my meditation you know that
that push and pull
if it wasn't the case that
we were
subject to our subconscious we would
never do anything that we didn't want to
do
but all the time we do stuff that we
don't want to do we press the snooze
button even though we committed to
ourselves that we weren't going to press
this news button we don't meditate we
forget to ring our mum we do whatever it
might be like all of these things are
because there is something else going on
and sex is one of you know on the bottom
of maslow's hierarchy of needs it is one
of the fundamental elements
it's like saying
i told myself i was going to fast for a
week but i broke after two days like
that must be because i'm a bad person
because i can't do the fast thing it's
like no your biology is very very geared
towards you not starving in the same way
as your biology is geared towards you
if you have the opportunity to have
attachment-free sex to do that but again
over time you know this is how long have
you been in
this sort of mode six months maybe one
year yeah about six months yeah and how
long had you spent idolizing women
probably ten years no so well said you
know say you give yourself your advice
from earlier on
yeah that's actually
i very much appreciate you just saying
that actually just hit me with my own
advice because
it is hard man it's i know the dangers
of casual sex and i openly even speak
against them on my channel because
for a while i branched away from it in
the sense okay women shouldn't have i
was in one of those gay women shouldn't
have casual sex but you know for men
where men are different and high value
men can do it but shut up bro but now i
realize like after speaking to
another youtuber elliot hulse and
speaking about fatherlessness it's
caused by both men and women engaging in
casual sex that it's the issue it's like
there is
just a complete detriment to society
when either one of us engages in that
activity because it just leaves a
generation of fatherless boys and then
those fatherless boys are more likely to
continue the same thing and it's the
hard times great strong men
paradigm that's happening
has your camera just gone that's all
right did you hear that yeah
i was so again this jeffrey miller thing
i was listening to earlier on i would
add one book in i'm only halfway through
it's called mate and it's by jeffrey
miller and tucker max and it's an
evolutionary psychologist and a guy
that's partied for a decade um become
the man women want and it's just it's
like it's a bit of a cringe title but i
guess it gets across what it is i think
it'd be a really interesting read for
girls as well to go through i think
models by mark manson as well is really
interesting for girls to see their own
neat that neediness
dynamic basically mark says that one of
the fundamental
um dynamics that goes on between men and
women is a level of neediness and that
neediness from a man is fundamentally
unattractive and basically that's what
you need to avoid at all costs one of
the best ways to not be needy is to have
a life that doesn't need anybody else in
to make it fulfilled you you are enough
and then somebody joins and you make a
life that is better together for both of
you as opposed to you are not enough
you're insufficient and a girl comes in
and fills the void because then you're
constantly going to be pining after that
girl and also it's a weak position to
negotiate from but so in this this is
[ __ ] eight years ago man right
jeffrey miller who wrote the mating mind
which is
like
one of the foundations for pretty much
everything else that grew out of it jeff
miller says that only ten percent of the
pickup and manosphere world understands
his work he reckons that more than fifty
percent of his sales were to the
manosphere and even though they idolized
jeffrey almost none of them understand
his work the entire point was to
understand what women want but no one
focuses on it
so what what is the the summary that
you've gotten from that that work so far
uh it's a a list of five different
things and in there is tell the truth
like one of the one of the things is to
constantly tell the truth to build up
self-esteem in yourself another one is
to
um not work with bias but to work with
uh rationality uh i wonder i'd be
interested to find out where the
rational mail came from i wonder whether
that was an influence on on rollo and
what he did but it's not got this sort
of very naggy
very distasteful degenerate sort of
zero-sum mentality at all you sent me
this video of the future is polyamorous
what do you reckon about the future of
relationships can you see that happening
yeah 100 i watched that video and
honestly really open up my my eyes after
i watch your podcast with uh vincent
yeah um so you guys are discussing the
sexual market place and how it's gonna
just get more and more cutthroat so i
made like a one-hour video in response
where i was just kind of like just you
know engaged in ideas and just seeing
what would happen
and
we're entering some dark times for young
men the fact that i think near the end
of your podcast you were really like
started taking the back thinking of like
the seriousness of this problem like i
don't think we you know we're just kind
of chatting now you know how to get
girls and everything but this is like
this is maybe one of those problems yeah
this quite literally is like a 10 out of
10 like
disaster just waiting time like it's
happening right now and everyone's not
really taking it serious because it's
just like oh you know like guys just
want to get laid but
it's a huge huge problem and the idea is
okay what is going to happen in the
future of dating well
relationships amongst young people and
even sex is like it's just going out of
place no one's really getting into like
a monogamous committed long-term
relationship the people who are getting
into monogamous relationships are often
finding that their relationships end six
to 12 months later and ending like
infidelity and everything
and the idea is that women just keep you
know with hypergamous nature they just
keep wanting better and better and
better better better men and because
the top men that all the women want are
ruthlessly competitive
ruthlessly competitive it's like this
this section of men let's say the top 10
is becoming ever harder to get into
let's say 50 years ago it was like he
didn't stink and he had a car and all
the girls who were after it but now it's
like you need everything you need like
you need six-pack you've been training
for six years in the gym you need like
your the mental it like confidence and
the degree post-graduate graduate degree
you need everything these days as a man
to like be in this top ten percent so
it's just gonna get more and more
ruthless women want the men in here the
thing is the men in here don't just want
one woman if you're the guy who's
essentially beaten 90 something percent
of other guys in terms of
characteristics chances are like a lot
of guys do say like you know oh no just
like i just want one woman if you had
the ability to to attract more than one
woman
i think the overwhelming majority guys
would actually accept that proposal and
be with two women instead in like let's
say in a dating market and i think we're
gonna see this more and more and i think
alexander grace the youtuber who made
that video of polygamy being normal he
had this fantastic point where he said
that he thinks feminists are actually
going to push this narrative not men
because it's going to be like this sort
of like new age fight for like more
rights in the sense where like women
would rather be
women it's roller masters quote women
would rather share an alpha than be
saddled with a fateful data
if that's the case
if the next frontier for feminism
is opening up
polyamorous relationships it's
poliginous relationships technically um
if that's the next frontier for them
i
i don't think that the future looks very
good for civilization because that is if
that's a cause that women start to
campaign for
that's the sort of thing that men are
going to riot
and
kill about
and
there's such a cool study have you ever
seen that graph before the one where
he'd uh what was that guy's name
the youtuber alexander grace yep um
where alexander had found a graph that
showed the relative number of men versus
the relative number of women that were
giving birth to children presumably this
must be genetic data somehow and um
you can see that from about 50 000 years
ago until 10 000 years ago it's
relatively equal like women are a little
bit higher because on average
women are more successful at having
children than men are women are a little
bit higher men are a little bit lower
but kind of tracking similarly and then
10 000 years ago the men just drop off a
cliff go to basically zero it looks like
who who which men uh having children
here there's no there's no one and his
argument was that during the
agricultural revolution what you had was
the ability for men to accrue status and
resources which afforded them the
ability to have huge harams of women
that they could keep safe
but then what they realized was that it
was an incredibly unstable society for
men to be in and i had an evolutionary
biologist on the show joe henrich the
other day and he said that
a lot of
south pacific islands and uncontacted
tribes and stuff that have been studied
some of them have a what's called a it's
like a
gentriatric i think
or a ger gerific or something uh which
is the old people are the ones that are
in charge um and
men have to go through a number of
rituals
before they can marry and often it keeps
them until their 30s before they can do
you've got to do this go do this go do
this go do this but what that leaves you
with is a ton of available women that
are captured by a bunch of old men and
then a [ __ ] ton of young men that are
coming up that think i've got to do my
next ritual in three years time i can't
get a woman at the moment because
they've all been captured by these guys
and these stupid rituals and this
ideology that we've got [ __ ] it let's
revolt and it's just an inherently
unstable society so that's the thing
nobody wants that
nobody wants that society when they
actually look at it nobody wants the
unstable sexless underclass of men
roaming the streets [ __ ] like that's bad
for
absolutely everybody
and
i don't know i don't know if
polygeny
is
as realistic
as alexander makes out
because
modern notions of romanticism
have skewed what women expect
a lot and i think that it's not
sufficient for
women in a relationship to simply get
their fair share of resources they
actually want to feel emotional
connection and time with their partner
and if you end up having you know one
man to three women or one man to four
women like is one quarter of that man's
attention going to be enough for you
i'm not sure
there's so many things to break down
there but the last point that you made
um in terms of the media influencing
because that's that's huge the media
very very heavily influences our dating
and our sexual lives and it was a
realization that i had let's say 50
years ago disney was a huge thing that
pushed forward like the blue pill
ideology and like the one-itis belief
you know like they got happily married
like happily ever after what's very
interesting is like
that media is very very different like i
don't consume much media but i can
almost like envision sort of like new
age sitcoms and you know like reality tv
shows where it's like
the modern stuff of the day and we
you're seeing it in the show you're
gonna see this one girl who like oh she
just had a drunken hookup with this guy
who didn't text her back and like she
wants this guy but this guy's got this
other guy and maybe she'll go on a date
and you know they had a threesome
together or something you're beginning
to see it because media influences us
but we also influence like the media and
of course some random show that shows
these dynamics is going to be quite
relatable amongst a certain audience so
we are going to see like the
i don't watch it personally but like i
know for a fact there's going to be some
tv shows that are like doing really well
right now which will have quite a
prominent character being a part of this
like modern new age dating
well dude think about what love island
does love island
turns i'm [ __ ] a part of this problem
right i
understand that it's the pot calling the
cattle black
they turn dating
into a game
like it's it is a game show first and
foremost after everything after you've
been through six weeks
there's been vote-offs there's been
surprise editions there's been casa amor
people have come in you've been worried
about losing this partner it's been this
really intense experience you've been
you've got a wicked tan and at the very
end you've won
here's some celebrations oh wait now you
get to play
would i lie to you or deal or no golden
balls you get to do split or steal and
i've always been really interested about
why that was there and i asked the guys
on my season like what was going on with
that
but what it tells us like it's the final
thing that you see
on the entire season you watch the whole
season it's the it's the [ __ ]
parentheses or it's the period at the
end right the full stop is will you
split or steal this 50 000 quid which is
a pointless exercise now because the
money that you make off the back of it
if you've made it to the end and you've
won is so much more and if you were to
steal the amount of money that you would
make from your boohoo sponsorship would
go through the floor because you
wouldn't have as much brand equity
anymore because you'd be the dick that
stole
25 grand um
it just reminds everyone that it's a
game
that's what it does
it's a show that is called love island
that is ostensibly supposed to be about
love and at the end of it it reminds
everyone
that actually it wasn't so much about
the relationship there was this game
show element to it as well
that doesn't seem like a tremendously
effective romantic
way
to teach young people about
caring about their relationship
everyone's swapping beds
twice a week new guys come in oh i like
it i know i'm with him but i like him i
know i'm with her but i'm gonna like
what's what does rolo call it uh branch
swinging
yeah i'm gonna branch swing across this
or i'll dip my toe in and see whatever's
going on
[ __ ] man
that's so interesting a show called love
island is heartless
that's uh that's like the modern dating
that we're literally surrounding
ourselves and of course this is like to
an extreme level and it's for the
audience the viewership and everything
but
honestly they're not that far off normal
dating lives anyway a lot of it is
recreating what people in in like let's
say the young party casual sex scene or
experience in because otherwise honestly
like if you're someone who's been like a
bit of a fuckboy you go to clubs and
everything like you know that dynamic
that's why it's so relatable and so fun
to watch because the questions that
you're asking people is like the
questions i'm asking some girl that i
just met yesterday and then there's like
oh there's another guys you're gonna mug
me off of the girl and everything like
it's so realistic but just when you
really think about the fact that it's
literally just like
all over the place like this is modern
dating is just kind of like the fast
food version of
the healthy version that we may have
gotten to experience like 100 years ago
[ __ ] i don't know and but i also don't
understand like i agree i think the one
items thing disempowers people from bad
relationships you know this is the part
of rollo's work that i think he really
nailed which is this myth of the one
there is not one person out there for
you there are a number of people that
are uh variably appropriate and the goal
is to find somebody that is as close to
appropriate as possible now that's not
to say that you can't feel incredibly
special and like you have a team in a
community and this is what you're going
to do and especially once you have kids
like okay like this is
with together through thick and thin
here you know i don't want my kids to
grow up in a single-parent household i'm
going to do everything i can to make
sure that that doesn't happen
i don't know how you blend
love island's
transient transactional relationships
with the myth of oneitis
with progression
for
women and men to not have rights removed
from them and norms removed from them
that restrict their premarital sex
with the challenges in women raising up
through the dominance hierarchy and
there being few and fewer men
hypergamously that are attracted to them
i'm like all of this blended together
just to me
do you know what it is man it feels like
[ __ ] don't look up
which is the new netflix show about an
asteroid that's coming toward earth and
these
couple of researchers are screaming at
the president of the united states and
saying
this is going to come and this is going
to kill us
we need to do something about it right
now
and nobody listens and they say well you
say it's 99.9 let's call it 70. we'll
get a press release out there like no no
no don't call it [ __ ] 70. this is a
big deal this is a planet killer and
then
it ends up being
everybody gets destroyed
i've tried to write my mind around the
potential solution to all this and i i
can't think of any good answers
whatsoever and
the only one that comes to mind
is
things keep going the way that they are
and instead of the bottom 80 of sexless
intimacy love deprived men revolting
they all just get consumed by the
metaverse and that's their new reality
and they find a sense of like love and
i'll be deadly serious i think that's
actually the most realistic scenarios a
few years from now we have like ultra
realistic sort of like virtual reality
and guys are just trading an hour of
cuddling for like 0.1 ethereum and
that's that'll do that dude i mean
you'll see this in your youtube comments
i've definitely seen it in some of the
red pill videos that i've done
where
guys will say the more mgtow we black
pill guys will say
um don't need to bother with women just
wait for the sex robots and buy cars in
the in the meantime
and i'm thinking well i mean
it's a solution
it's not i wouldn't say it's an optimal
solution it's not the one that i would
choose but
i understand the compulsion of a guy who
feels like he can't get physical
intimacy or find a woman or a wife that
cares about him
i understand why that would be
attractive and
maybe you're right maybe the best
the second best option if revolt is the
worst option maybe the second best
option is sedation
if you sedate
the populace
with
enough
metaverse and virtual reality and
convenience to the point where
people genuinely men genuinely don't
care about mating anymore but even that
man like i can't imagine
me being that guy
i don't that's not the sort of life that
i want and again i understand that
not everybody has the same life
experiences but
[ __ ] that like did you did you really
want to grow up for this to be the
pinnacle of your life
to be honest i feel like the sedation is
already has been happening for many many
years video games porn social media i
think
the majority of guys are so consumed in
in this technology
that they wouldn't ever revolt
and
like life is like good enough for the
majority of guys and
the things that they miss from real life
like a sense of brotherhood status and
recognition they're getting in games
like call of duty the things that
they're missing the date in a sexual
market because they're not part of you
know the 20 guys who are like allowed to
get that stuff they get from like
i don't know tv shows and porn and just
fantasies and
sending dick pics on instagram so
although it doesn't exist essentially a
fulfill the exact need the thing is the
businesses that
sedate a person and make them feel like
somewhat like they've ticked off those
bottom pillars of mazel's hierarchy of
needs those industries are like billions
like hundreds of billions because that's
that's where
billions of men are going to
and to be honest you were saying like
you couldn't imagine a life like this
that made me realize okay
usually if i do see those mem those
comments of like the men saying men
going their own way and black pill you
know usually i'm instantly like okay you
loser like i don't know why you're doing
that just you know focus on
self-improvement everything but lately i
because of your podcast i've been
thinking more about this and i've been
thinking
are men like you and i live in our life
through the lens of someone who isn't
genetic this sounds horrible like
genetically sort of subpar
and that's why we're saying things like
oh you know i wouldn't want to live that
life but it's like
we're tall attractive guys we've got
like these good features and everything
we couldn't imagine a life like that but
what about for the guy
we couldn't imagine life like that even
if you know things were worse off
because we'd be okay you know let's go
get the six pack at the money and
everything but what about the guy who's
like literally five foot seven
unattractive face you know what's weird
did you watch oh again you don't use a
massive amount of social media but
molly may who won love island a couple
of years ago she trended on twitter uh
this week because she made some pretty
tone-deaf comments about how
people that are poor just need to work
harder and they can do whatever they
want and someone mentioned that she
works for pretty little thing and gets
six hundred thousand pounds a year but
pretty little thing pay their workers
three pounds fifty so it's very
difficult it doesn't matter how hard i
work i'm stuck in a poverty trap and it
kind of feels
maybe a little bit like that that there
is a degree of blindness to
people for whom there is a ceiling on it
on their capacity for growth personal
agency sovereignty so the black pill in
in cell forums on average it's
30 of people
to 50 of people have some sort of autism
spectrum disorder so they're aspergic
autistic or they might be disabled
physically
and you think
when you learn that stat you're like
me telling you that you need to go read
atomic habits by james clear just
doesn't cut the mustard but i mean
frankly i don't think that me or you
were speaking to them
like that's not my audi bro like i feel
for you
you know there is a channel of
interesting content for you here but
genuinely i feel like your
situation requires more specialist
assistance than i can give it
um this is for the this is written for
the me and you 10 years ago right that's
what the content is created therefore
and to pick out any anything that you
say is a generalization and to pick out
that
one example that doesn't fit the
generalization you're like oh okay cool
but i can't make a one size fits [ __ ]
everybody's solution here we're just
trying to give across the best tactics
that we found that work for us that will
hopefully apply to the widest group of
guys and girls
thirty to fifty percent man
it's interesting what you said like our
our content is not really calling out to
them for me
the reason why i do try to like help
these guys and i make videos for the
guys who are going to talk to losers and
everything is because i've been there
and
honestly like i would i could have been
an insult at this point and it's so
interesting okay everyone would be
completely no hamster you're six foot
one you've got the jawline your genetics
like face and everything but i could
have been and like honestly i wasn't
that far off at that point to be black
pilled and everything
if i stumbled down onto like the black
pill subreddit if there was one at the
time you know if i started engaging in
that type of content i probably would
have been one of these guys saying like
no it's over for me because i'm brown
skin and everything in fact that was
like one of the beliefs i genuinely
thought i was like ugly because i was
brown skin and no girls wanted me and
then it just something just hit me i
think i started weightlifting at first
and you know you envision the body i
just thought hang on if i've got like a
10 out of 10 body i'm still brown bro
like i'm still going to be attractive
like there's definitely brown guys who
are like getting girls right now so it
isn't the fact that i'm brown that i'm
not you know getting the success that i
want
but
i don't think we're relatable like at
all to
a large chunk of men and i think a
big part of that was obviously the
characteristics that they say you know
like
negative candle till they've got some
good terms like
hunter eyes and prey eyes so you've got
so hunter eyes is like where your eyes
are like um almond shaped and they're
quite close to your eye this is autistic
like quite close to your eyebrows and it
makes you look like a hunter in the
sense of like you know wolf has like
those eyes okay and then prey eyes are
like circular like i've got prey eyes
which are like that's what they always
say they make videos about me they're
like hubs it's got prey eyes and stuff
it's like they say like he's got a good
jawline he's six foot one he's
attractive and everything but his eye
region lets him die
it's going to do it's bad like
i'm wearing glasses and stuff now
there's like prey eyes are more like
circular eyes like you know like rabbit
eyes so you can see more of a scoop
around you
but you know what's very interesting
there is an open coming black pill
youtuber called wheat waffles and he was
like um like treading the path for the
black pill content just a few months ago
i got him onto a podcast and we argue a
lot and everything we're disagreeing
with each other and it was like a very
very bad sort of episode and everything
but then we speak more and more we
literally become friends and then for
the second episode a lot of people
realize he's kind of changed his mindset
on a fair amount of things and just out
of nowhere obviously he was arguing
things like no hamsa what you're
teaching is like a scam and getting fit
getting the muscular body doesn't work
and everything that was on the first
episode on the second one he just
randomly says yeah like the most
important thing you can do is build the
muscular body
i was like wait that's like that's red
pelvis and even like he's changed his
mind and he he this is these guys are
like you know like you said um very math
like they're into math and data and all
this so he's done like a face analysis
of a thousand people quantified they've
got the graphs and everything like this
artistic level stuff the highest thing
like the best thing that a man can do to
improve how attractive he is to a woman
and he quantifies so many different
things it's loose fat build muscle
everything else was way less than that
surgery and height and all this stuff
lose fat build muscle he said that
pretty much every guy should at least
try to do this at least try to build
that body first and then find out if you
like should be black pilled and even
though that advice is a bit like like i
kind of agree that's what i've been
saying to a lot of guys before you take
the black pill before you want to be an
intel try to build a 10 out of 10.
like do five three one three three
months buy books
at least build like the six out of ten
ten out of ten body and then just see
how you feel after that if after that
you say okay still no attraction from
women whatsoever bro i'll cry with you
but i can't imagine there's a guy who's
got the full aesthetic body and like the
low body fat percentage that comes with
it who still says that he completely
struggles with women and that it hasn't
gotten better at all and if even if
there's a small majority of men who say
it hasn't got better at all i guarantee
those guys would still not stop lifting
because it's just become like a part of
their identity and they really like the
win
yeah so awesome you talk about
we've mentioned on the channel before
about how on tinder there is the bottom
80 percent of men competing for the
bottom 20 women top 80 women competing
for the top 20 of men the inference from
that is if you're not physically in the
top if you're not an 8 out of 10
relative or above as a guy then you are
by definition in the bottom part now one
of the things
that i think guys especially young guys
that are listening need to know is that
on average your competition for guys
that are developing themselves is so
piss-poor
that you don't actually need to be
in the 80th percentile of anything you
only need to be slightly better than the
massive amount of guys that are not
doing anything at all this is like
about guys that are going to the gym
if you go to the gym three times a week
you're in probably the top one percent
or five percent of fit people
on the planet
like and especially in a western country
like america or the uk but
i think on average
everybody's overweight in both countries
yeah on average you're obese
the bar is set so [ __ ] low for you to
be a guy that goes to the gym that
listens to some charisma on command
stuff that takes a little bit from a
podcast you don't need to spend a ton of
money you don't need to what you don't
even need to work that [ __ ] hard like
you do not need to work that hard the
bar is set so low for charisma for
confidence for looks for everything
because it's not about becoming an eight
out of ten compared to the people on
instagram it's like that story about if
you're in a wood and you worried about
being chased down by a bear you don't
need to be faster than the bear you just
need to be faster than the [ __ ] guy
next to you
honestly i love this thinking like i
made one of my favorite random videos
that i made was just titled your
competition and i was trying to tell the
boys
you've got to stop thinking that you
need to be like up here like a lot of
guys will you know defeat this mindset
but like you know i'm not going to go
make 200k a year in like six foot seven
and like all this like you don't need to
be that good of course like it helped
that would be nice the thing is your
competition right now for the average
guy who's watching this who jacks off
five times a week and he plays video
games for like one hour a day but it's
more like four the thing is if you do a
push-up today you have literally beaten
500 million men
how can that not blow your mind and if
you go and do like a good structured
program you're being pretty much every
single guy apart from like
the five guys at your gym who are
actually on a program themselves you do
that for three years four years whilst
also like working on your career or a
business and you've got some like
fantastic traits and not only that you
put like you're just happy like okay
let's even forget about women like you
built a body that you're proud of you
feel like you know you like
pain some respect disease and you feel
shredded and everything and now you
build some money so you can actually go
and enjoy some experiences if you forget
about women for any sense at all
your life's just gotten infinitely
better just by slightly thinking of your
competition of the men around you and i
wish more guys could just realize that
you're not inco like you are absolutely
somewhat we're all in competition
together but the thing is you the way i
explain it is like we're all in
competition but we're in separate races
and if you're just starting off you're
on the race of jefferies and those guys
they're not even they're running in the
wrong direction they're like just doing
some like weird [ __ ] like they're
running the wrong race all you're going
to do is beat jeffrey today and then
okay beat those guys who beat jeffrey
yesterday it's just progressive overload
in all sense of your life
don't man we made it hamza ladies and
gentlemen people want to check out your
channel where should they go the search
hands are on youtube they'll be the
first that's a flex that'll be it'll be
the first one that pops up boss have you
got your plaque have you got your silver
plaque man i put in the details and
everything they take a while on the
delivery but we're on like 220k now
flying man look dude i've really enjoyed
speaking to you i think your content is
dope keep adding thank you chris thank
you for having me man
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace